there's a new theory about what may have
caused a large oil spill which is having
a major impact on the southern
california coast up to 144 000 gallons
of oil have already spilled into the
ocean there shutting down beaches and
putting animals in danger lilia luciano
reports from huntington beach
crews on and off shore continue working
along huntington beach cleaning up one
of the largest oil spills the area has
ever seen monday the ceo of amplify
energy which operates the pipeline said
there's a possibility a ship's anchor
may have ruptured the line we have
examined more than eight thousand feet
of pipe
and we have isolated one specific area
of significant interest captain rebecca
orr is overseeing operations for the u.s
coast guard we do not know the cause at
this time what has been the most
challenging of the efforts so far the
unpredictability is really the most
complex part we don't know precisely how
much is out there despite concerns about
the impact on wildlife an initial
assessment found four oily birds so far
compared to the thousands discovered
during a spill in 1990. the number of
birds in the general area seems to be
lower than we had feared but at this
point we're cautiously optimistic
residents are now questioning whether
amplify energy and state agencies acted
quickly enough
locals reported noticing an oil sheen
and a heavy petroleum smell friday night
still the company ceo maintains that
crews didn't discover a problem until a
line inspection the next day saturday
morning when we found the sheen that's
when we kicked in the incident command
like i said so we were not aware of
anything friday night for cbs morning's
lilia luciano in huntington beach
california